the Spanish Inquisition has a certain
reputation it is seen as a bastion of
near indiscriminate torture and
corruption and of brutal repressions of
Jews and Muslims to put it bluntly it's
an institution with a bad reputation but
just how bad was the Spanish Inquisition
really where they really as terrible as
they were made out to be or resist the
result of historical disinformation
now obviously the Spanish Inquisition
was a long-lived body that operated
differently in different areas and was
also reformed several times the way it
did things were subject to change
depending on circumstances and as such
we're going to focus on the period
during the reign of King Philippe ii
just to narrow things down and the
reason why is that this is the period in
which the inquisition was said to be at
its worst before continuing there's
something that does need to be said
though most people expected the Spanish
Inquisition because when a person was
being prosecuted they would give you
roughly a mumps notice so the Spanish
Inquisition was tasked with one thing to
rid Spain of any threats to the Catholic
faith the primary crime they were
looking for was of course heresy
although they did investigate things
like witchcraft so at the time the
accusation of witchcraft in the
practicing of magic was a fairly common
one whilst many people at the time did
believe in witchcraft it's important to
note that the Catholic Church and by
extension the Spanish Inquisition were
very skeptical
the majority of witchcraft cases ended
with acquittal and those who were found
guilty of making false claims were often
fined for those who would unknowingly
committed acts of heresy or claim to be
healers or somesuch their punishment
wasn't death but public penance although
if you were found guilty of being a
witch
you'd be tortured and killed but what
about the Inquisition's main focus
what about heretics well the Inquisition
had been founded to confirm the
conversion of mariscos and conversos who
were former Muslims and Jews who had
been commanded to convert or leave Spain
in the late 15th century these people
were often harassed by the Inquisition
and in many cases they were expected to
pay bribes in order to be left alone so
what if someone was caught with non
Catholic religious texts or word god
forbid a protestant for a start they
certainly be tortured although the
inquisition actually did this less than
secular authorities this would go on
until you confessed or until an
Inquisitor decided on whether or not you
were guilty foreign traders who were
Protestants were often tortured before
being fined and then expelled from Spain
these people then wrote of their ordeals
which were widely disseminated across
the Protestant world hence the
Inquisition's reputation for those who
were guilty didn't repent or couldn't
pay their way out the punishment was
after
death fire burning you should be aware
though that there weren't many of these
and only about 2% of all trials ended
with an execution so to conclude by
modern standards the Spanish Inquisition
was pretty brutal it was driven by a
near rabid hatred of other religions it
was corrupt in its demands for bribes
and it was responsible for widespread
torture and executions by medieval
standards they were often much better
than the alternative they required
evidence for trials they were skeptical
of any accusations and their torture was
often less severe and the Spanish
Inquisition was one of the first
institutions to dismiss confessions
obtained by torture so whilst they were
bad for the time they weren't that bad
compared to other inquisitions
especially the Roman Inquisition they
were quite lenient I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with the special thanks to my patreon
supporters James Bissonnette calling
Castleman Danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds James Castaneda
Gustav Swan Marcus Ozma Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swan Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three plates filled
- oink oink David Silverman Izzy
Winston Hayward Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Anthony
Beckett